[Musique]
dans le sud de la france une grotte
découverte dans les années 90 abrite une
structure et un autre fait de
stalagmites cet assemblage unique au
monde vient de faire l'objet de
nouvelles analyses qui montre qu'il a
été construit il ya 175 mille ans à
l'époque de l'homme de néandertal la
grotte de bruniquel force donc les
experts à réviser leurs connaissances
sur le mode de vie de cet hominidé
dans le sud de la france la vallée de
l'aveyron offre des vues spectaculaires
des forêts luxuriantes ponctué
d'escarpements rocheux au fil du temps
l'eau s'est infiltrée dans les
formations calcaires de la région et la
sculpter ses paysages grandioses
auxquels s'ajoutent des constructions
humaines non moins splendide comme le
village de bruniquel et son château
médiéval enfoui quelque part sous ce
décor magnifique se cache une
construction encore bien plus ancienne
dans une grotte que des gens ont
fréquenté il y a des dizaines de
milliers d'années ils ont édifié une
structure mystérieuse unique au monde
dont les scientifiques commencent à
peine à comprendre la portée
nous avons compris que ce sont
pratiquement les plus anciennes
constructions en europe est presque dans
le monde en tout cas aussi bien conservé
c'est parmi les plus anciennes
conservées construction au monde et en
grottes sont les seules la grotte de
bruniquel a été découverte dans les
années 90 par des spéléologues amateurs
il y trouve des tanières d'ours mais
surtout un étrange assemblage de
stalagmites sur la structure des
archéologues prélève d'un os d'ours
calcinés son analyse révélera qu'il a au
moins quarante cinq mille ans l'âge
donné à donner un âge supérieur à c'est
à dire qu'on est en limite de la méthode
la méthode de carbone 14 permet de dater
de la matière organique mais jusqu'à une
serre jusqu'à un certain âge
donc voilà l'interprétation c'est que ce
vestige avaient un âge supérieur à la
datation qui est indiquée
suite au décès de l'archéologue
responsable des recherches
la grotte va rester un secret bien gardé
pendant près de 20 ans en 2014
jacques jaubert a finalement retourné à
bruniquel avec des collègues pour tenter
de préciser l'âge de la fameuse
structure la géologue belge sophie
verheyden participe à l'expédition
l'entrée de la grotte est très étroite
les constructions se trouvent trois
cents mètres plus loin dans les
profondeurs dans un décor quelques
heures sur un sol couvert d'eau alors tu
vois la grande structure qui fait
environ 7 mètres de long sur 4 m à 4 m
et demi de large et constitue aussi de
stalagmites brisé ringer et sur
l'ensemble de ces deux structures il y a
environ 400 morceaux qui ont été cassés
et régis 420 morceaux de stalagmites
empilés qui représente plus de deux
tonnes de matériaux ils ont été disposés
en un grand cercle et un second plus
petit une construction
manifestement humaine selon les
spécialistes
ils ont non seulement arraché les
stalagmites mais après ils ont recoupé
ils ont calibre et ils ont sectionné et
donc on a une espèce de briques standard
de stalagmites kit dont ils se sont
servis pour ses constructions
après ils les ont superposé on a un deux
trois et même jusqu'à quatre rangs de
stalagmites qui sont agencés les uns
au-dessus des autres comme des assises
d'un mur en pierres sèches
après ils ont même et glisser des
éléments pour stabiliser le taux de la
construction et là ce sont autant
d'éléments qui ne peuvent pas être
d'origine animale l'ours ne construit
pas avec des stalagmites dans les
grottes et la nature n'est pas aussi
subtil que le que l'être humain pour
fabriquer ce genre de structure les
chercheurs entame alors une série d'
analyse dans l'espoir d'interpréter la
mystérieuse structure
pour connaître son âge exact
les scientifiques prélèvent des
échantillons dans les concrétions qui la
composent
formé par l'eau calcaire qui s'égoutte
dans les grottes les stalagmites
croisent au fil du temps cette
croissance s'est arrêtée quand les
concrétions été cassé par dessus de
nouvelles stalagmites ont poussé les
échantillons prélevés à la pointe des
concrétions brisé fournissent un âge
maximum pour la structure se découper à
la base des repousses fournée son âge
minimum en analysant la désintégration
des isotopes d'atomes d'uranium en
thorium dans ces carottes
les scientifiques ont déterminé l'âge
probable de la structure 176 1500 un
choc pour les préhistoriens on aurait
été vraiment très content d'avoir ces
âges de 30 millions de 25 mille ans 40
me dont les rêves les plus fous
mais quand sophie m'a téléphoné et
qu'elle m'a dit que c'était 176 milan
franchement j'étais complètement en
arrêt j'ai mis un certain temps avant de
réaliser que cet âge était très ancien
il des conséquences de ces dotations en
effet cette date est un gigantesque bond
en arrière dans le temps elle fait
reculer d'au moins 130 mille ans ce
qu'on croyait connaître de
l'appropriation humaines du monde sous
terre en comparaison homo sapiens
fréquentait la grotte del castillo en
espagne ou encore celle de chauvet dans
le sud est de la france
il y a entre 30 et 40 mille ans s'était
jusqu'ici deux des plus anciennes
preuves d'activités humaines sous terre
mais à une époque où circulent et que
175 bilan l'homme moderne vie en afrique
il n'est pas encore arrivée en europe il
n'ya donc qu'un seul responsable
possible à bruniquel lemasson des
profondeurs c'est l'homme de néandertal
bouleversement de ce que les experts
tenait jusqu'ici pour acquis j'ai
expliqué plusieurs fois que j'étais
vraiment spécialiste des des sociétés de
néandertal de ces cultures de leurs
technologies de leur mode de vie et nous
avons des standards on a des bilans on a
des paradigmes
on sait à peu près comment il fonctionne
et on savait j'ai même écrit plusieurs
fois qu'il n'allait pas dans les grottes
qui n'était pas appropriée le monde
souterrain
il faut une fois de mettre ces nouveaux
résultats et j'ai changé notre logiciel
mais qu'allait donc faire néandertal
dans cette galerie souterraine s'abriter
stocker de la nourriture pratiques et
des rituels pour l'instant le mystère
reste entier
le travail des chercheurs ne fait que
commencer
on sait pas ce qu'on peut faire sur un
site comme ça une fois qu'on a les
datations bon ok ça 180 mille ans 175
bilan mais que maintenant qu'est-ce
qu'on en fait on va faire un travail on
va dire à distance ce qu'on appelle non
invasif on va essayer de préciser encore
des éléments de cette construction mais
on va pas la démonter
[Musique]
à quelques centaines de kilomètres de la
grotte à l'université de bordeaux
les chercheurs poursuivent leurs
analyses ils se concentrent sur des
points précis de la structure qui
semblent avoir été brûlées
18 endroits le feu a laissé des marques
sur les constructions
quand on voit les concrétions assure
images on voit bien encore à l'âge et
aux archéologues catherine fériés et son
équipe tentent de comprendre comment
sont apparus les traces de combustion
qu'ils observent sur les stalagmites
parce que on se pose des questions sur
ce qu'ils étaient ses feux de point de
vue puissance leur intensité de la
quantité de combustible qu'il était
nécessaire pour les alimenter et pour
produire ses marques et thermique qu'on
observe sur le terrain et puis aussi on
se pose la question du combustible la
nature puisque ont été retrouvés du
charbon dos mais on peut tout à fait
imaginer qu'ils aient aussi alimenter
ses feux avec du bois donc il fallait
aussi tester les deux types de
combustibles
les chercheurs ont tenté de recréer un
de ces foyers plusieurs essais ont été
menés avec du pin sylvestre un voies
disponibles dans la région à l'époque et
des eaux d'herbivores avec une dizaine
de kilos de combustible du bois ou un
mélange de bois et hausse les
expérimentateurs ont réussi à atteindre
les températures nécessaires pour
provoquer des altérations de couleurs
variées similaire à celle observée dans
la grotte
c'est pas des grosses quantités donc on
sait que la structure elle est un peu
plus de 300 mètres de l'entrée donc on a
un ordre de grandeur de la quantité de
combustible en point qu'il fallait
transporter
des simulations numériques et d'autres
expérimentations permettront de préciser
comment ces feux se serait comporté dans
un espace confiné comme la grotte de
bruniquel
mais déjà une différence notable
apparaît entre les deux types de
combustibles le bois il faut alimenter
pour maintenir la combustion de manière
à obtenir les températures permettant
les termes aux altérations il faut
alimenter avec du bois vous savez très
bien tout le monde sait que ce feu si on
alimente pas il baisse en intensité en
revanche l'os vous pouvez une fois que
la combustion du bois et est en place
vous pouvez mettre une grosse quantité
dos et qu'on n'avait pas besoin de
réorganiser le foyer vous n'avez pas
besoin de vous en occuper
ce qui laisse complètement libre pour
faire d'autres activités en profitant de
la lumière émise par le par le feu donc
ça peut être intéressant dans la dans la
réflexion de comment quelle durée
comment ils ont pu s'organiser pour
faire cette grande structure
la grotte de bruniquel commence à peine
à livrer ses secrets
il faudra encore beaucoup de travail
pour espérer comprendre comment et
surtout pourquoi néandertal la
fréquenter mais d'ores et déjà sa
présence dans ces lieux souterrains nous
force à revoir notre perception de cet
homme préhistorique souvent dépeint
comme primitif la comparaison entre
l'humanité néandertalienne et les hommes
modernes qui sont contemporains en même
temps mais de l'autre côté de la
méditerranée est tout à fait et sur un
plan d'égalité complète en matière
d'innovation technique spirituel
économique voilà cdd d humanité qui ont
le même niveau de d'innovation et de et
de positionnement dans l'histoire des
techniques et il n'y a pas un retard des
néandertaliens par rapport aux hommes
modernes
bien au contraire et même bruniquel et
plutôt quelque chose qui qui montrent
ils sont dans ce domaine là plutôt en
avance sur leurs congénères africain